the basic thinking was wait a minute
everybody's speaking about r d
and technology but there's this huge
area of r d
of of new jobs or future jobs that i
want to be in
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with ctec
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders i am joined today by
sneer co-founder and ceo of elevation
avi is the founder and ceo of elevation
an entrepreneur husband father and
believer
he loves humus consistently lives in a
village outside of tel aviv
and spent his spare time wondering about
the future of work skills careers
and in between avi smir welcome to 20
minute leaders
good morning good morning thanks for
having me
thank you for having me and and in this
conversation right now i know how busy
you are so these 20 minutes or i'm going
to try to make them as special as
possible
talking both about your own journey um
into the world of
education tech and upskilling and
reskilling and online
transformations and but i'm also excited
to talk about the industry as a whole
and why why seven years ago did you
understand that we even have this need
what has happened to the world that you
said
we we need to have something like
elevation
and so avi i want you to take me back a
little bit
you know whether it's to your army days
or whether it's to your days
with herzog forks and fox and neiman
what what what is
going on with you where you understand
that there is a need
for some change in the way that people
get education
great great question so basically
uh i grew up in a small village it's
like
an hour south of tel aviv i didn't
really know about like all the
opportunities and the new skills and
tech my first job was in the fields
uh i grew up in like a small community
and uh when i went out of the art to the
army
uh i went to special forces i stayed
there
a bit longer like six seven years almost
and when i went out i didn't really knew
what i wanted to do
like all the others so um
i decided to do like this general ba
i call it and to learn a
low end business management in the idc
and herzeglia
and i knew i didn't want to be a lawyer
but i knew that i want i i need to
like get the roots in the ground to
actually start something of my own
my last position in the special forces
was the head of
uh school of like commando and this is
where i fell in love
with education and training and skills
it's it's different but it's kind of the
same and
i saw that uh when you look at the
um the life after the army especially in
israel
there's a lot of things that you can
bring over from the resilient side
from the skill side and then i started
my journey
in life okay like you said
i went to herzeg fox neymar it was like
the biggest low frame in israel
tech m a basically i just wanted to get
to know
better the industry the investors and
everybody around that
but it was a great journey and i
realized that
like me there's like a lot of people
around that don't really know what they
want to do
i looked at my grandparents both
grandfathers worked at the same place
for more than 40 years
okay one uh it started the the cowshed
in the village
and the other one worked in the israel
electric company
and it was kind of simple but our life
was
more complicated and i realized that
it's not around the position it's around
like
building your portfolio of micro careers
when you're looking at
yourself in this mee.com area looking at
yourself as a product
and it's not around the title it's
around
the skill set that you want to deal with
and the light that you want to bring to
to the universe
then i i read this article from oxford
stating that if you're looking at 2030
it was around 20
i think 13 or 14 60
of the best jobs then we don't know what
it's going to be
okay and we know that there is a lot of
jobs that going to disappear
and a lot of new jobs will come over and
it looks like
super exciting industry um
and the basic thinking was wait a minute
everybody speaking about r d
and technology but this huge area of
r d of of new jobs or future jobs
that i want to be in because i really
like around education
and it came together with all my agenda
for
from the maybe like more social part
of actually doing something that can
help people
change their lives it's not like all
startups saying
we're going to change the world okay i
wanted to change
people's life i know that we can start
small i can start with one people with
two people with five people
and on the way we found like different
ways
to actually do that this is why like i
started to think around it
it was back then when all the
accelerated learning programs started in
the us
general assembly and and all these are
big companies today
and in israel we basically had nothing
so this is how i started
so you're you're talking you know now at
scale
and you're you know you're projecting to
with with these reports that i i don't
think there's any contestation
as to their validity now obviously most
of the jobs that we know today are going
to be transformed in a dramatic way one
way or another
but before we before we head to there i
want to go back a little bit to maglan i
believe and
you know you also start elevation while
you're also in reserve duty
as a as a lieutenant colonel and
what is it about your experience with
mcglan and with the school over there
that that gave you the passion and the
insight for the world of education
because i'm always fascinated how do you
what was it that that really
said wow like this is this is really
really impactful
yeah so um back in the service
um i took like two years of being a
company commander of the training area
uh and all the time i i had like around
100 soldiers that we took them from
civilians to being like special forces
and and you saw
how training can be super
transformational
um after we went out of the army like
the reserve duty was a
kind of uh a hobby okay and it didn't
had like time for other hobbies because
it was
kind of intense uh but i think
there's like similar lines between
being a special forces unit commander to
being an entrepreneur
or ceo like founder of a startup okay
it's like small teams really mission
driven
uh really agile thinking have to react
really fast to what's happening
in the fields and how everybody
everything is changing so fast
and coming with this state of mind of
okay we have a plan but everything that
can
go wrong will go wrong so let's talk
about
the other options that we have the other
plans and kind of uh
be ready for everything and so
with this idea of being ready and being
open-minded and
understanding how how impactful you know
education can be
on a person and you know obviously most
israelis that
you know go through this sort of
training and understand
how how quickly and how dramatic it is
and i can only imagine in an elite unit
like magellan how how impactful it is to
be in the position you were at
you're creating elevation and you know
paint me a picture
of where we are today in terms of the
world of upskilling and
and what do you how do you actually see
the industry from sort of a bird's eye
view
in terms of you know education
reskilling upskilling
what is happening there
right so um basically when we started
elevation it was um
around the b to c and after like a year
we started to do both b to c and b to c
and b to b today uh we found uh roots to
work
only with b2b but it came from a few
perspectives
first of all we realized that
if you want to do a really good
education
it's kind of expensive and we find a way
that we can help people get new skills
and improve their life but have someone
else
to pay for that so we're working with a
lot of organizations with a government
with different non-profits
uh to fund a lot of
the different training that we have and
with the companies
to train their employees but when we
look at the industry
there is like this report from the world
economic forum every two years
around the future of jobs last one was
in october 2020
and it's again speaking about the rapid
change
the automation the shifting all the the
job market
by the way they now stating that in 2025
there is approximately 97 million jobs
that
will may disappear uh and
from the 885 million jobs that will
disappear and from the other hand
97 million jobs that can be like a new
uh the problem in the last year with the
coffee that
was the pace of of uh new jobs that
they're coming
was a kind of slower uh so it was a
like a problem but it's also stating
that
more than 40 percent of employees will
need some kind of a upskilling
due to the automation due to the new
technologies cloud
the data everything around that so
um it's coming together with the fact
that um ceos and sea levels
understand that this strategy and
learning and development in organization
kind of going through what marketing
went through maybe 12 years ago
from something that is like nice to have
to something that is really strategy of
the company
data-driven looking to see the roi the
return on investment
and this is where we came over
and we realized that today
companies doing one of the two options
they can do like online full online get
one of the websites and do subscription
for the employees and we know that the
completion rate is is quite
low and it's it's hard or they can start
their own
internal academy because uh it's kind of
heavy to do all the upskill risk skill
it's
it's not on the way uh we came over and
saw that
it's really hard for companies so we
want to build it for them
and this is what we're doing the mission
is to build internal capabilities
academies
to move the needle for strategic
strategic kpis that they have with the
same vision of changing people and and
companies life
through getting new tech skills
so a naive question one that i think has
to be asked
you know there's two options to go here
i'm
trying to simulate the way a ceo would
think
you can you know bring in um and and
upskill a lot of your workers and and
help them gain the
the talent and the skills necessary for
for the next phase or you can get new
talent right
you can get people that are fresh and
that that know these skills and and just
replace your workforce
from your from your point of view why
why is it obvious to you
that the latter is not the right
decision yet we
should instead focus on our current
talent and just
work on upskilling them in the
organization
yeah so build versus buy it's like one
of the major questions in the last
maybe two years before the covey
everybody spoke about
optimization of current workforce due to
the changes
and we know that if we're looking at the
numbers
it's easier and it's cheaper to do
reskill for your employees so if you
have an employee that's working
in a position or with a skill set that
you see that it's less relevant in the
future you can do with a really in a
really short time of uh of
training you can get him to uh another
place
we know that the cost of uh losing
someone or firing someone is really high
in the cost of hiring
and the time that it gets you to get the
right people
um if you're looking at the equation
it's better to do the risk
but the things needs to come in parallel
so we see uh huge organizations
that actually building huge upskill
programs uh specifically around
data skills uh trying to make the
organization more data driven
and in parallel finding the right people
and building this
uh small reskill programs that can take
people from
a to a different place within the
organization and it's not like companies
just like
google facebook or wix we're talking
about banks
we're talking about non-profit
organization we're talking about like
more traditional parts that we see it's
happening
so today with elevation let's say that
you're working with with a company a
traditional company you know a business
and you're coming and they're saying
listen avi we have this we
we have this need we have these
employees and we need them to understand
these different skill sets that
they don't yet have because these skills
weren't relevant you know even a few
years ago and so nobody acquired them
yet we want to upskill and reskill them
for the new digital age
how does it actually work tangibly
you're mentioning before that one of the
biggest challenges is to get to the
is to get to a you know an okay
completion rate which doesn't really
happen with the memberships to the
different websites
how does elevation you know work through
those
those inherent challenges that education
tech brings with it
great so um first of all we're coming
with the full solution
of services so we can help the company
better understand
the uh the kpis from the
business project project from the
business side
business objectives and from the
learning objective side
and then we can come with the right plan
for them
it's not always the same skill set to be
a data analyst in a
weeks it's different from to be a data
analyst in
one of the banks for example after that
we have like
our own a unique methodology the
training is blended
so it's bringing the best out of the
online and
in life let's say let's say you have a
live zoom training with the lead
trainers and you have this platform that
you can learn by yourself because we
want you to be in a place
uh that we give you the tools to keep
learning all the time
and the methodology is to do an
assessment to better understand where
you're at
and then do the training according to
your level
uh and at the end give the actual report
of the level of knowledge that you
gained
so it's not around just the completion
rate
although the completion rate in
elevation is more than 99
it's also around measuring the
the actual roi uh you invested time you
invested money
we can show you the level of knowledge
that you gained within
this journey and once we're realizing
which kpis we're serving uh
within the hr department it's it's easy
for us because
if it's like internal training around
time to hire time to feel of course to
firing
it's one thing if it's training program
around retention for employees
not necessarily with the skill set that
they need for their jobs
it's another thing what is something
that you learned about
you know the consumer behavior the
people that are going through
through these programs what is something
that you learned you know throughout
these
seven years that you said wow i didn't
anticipate this or
this is something that may that may be
surprising to the average listener
who who's now you know getting
introduced to this idea of of
reskilling and upskilling
yeah so so basically i learned that uh
it's all about the people and all people
are kind of the same
in the way that they want to gain the
new skills
and it it doesn't really matter if
you're working in in google in
non-profit or
in a traditional place it's more about
your state of mind and if you
really understand uh the benefits that
you're getting
from the organization in this program
and you understand like the bigger
picture of
wait a minute now i'm doing this but
and i love doing this area but it's
going to kind of disappear and i need to
find
the the other things that i can do with
my skill set or gain new skills
in order to to make my life better so
everybody is is up to the mission
and once they're realizing it everybody
is like learning the same
and we have like crazy stories from
places like that sent uh
someone that was like a front desk to a
a risk killing pro
program as a bonus they didn't count on
on him to come over and be an analyst
and he was like second in class and
become an analyst and things like this
so uh a lot of the people trying to get
to the market
they're going to have a degree because
someone told them that this is the right
way okay i'm not sure
and then they're starting with something
but they need to keep and realize what
they actually want to do
and sometimes when you're giving
opportunities to
people that you believe in you will find
out that they can
give more with their skill set and and
gain more and give more for the company
for sure
i love that avi 20 minutes go by way
too fast thank you for coming here and
sharing with me your
your journey and your experiences but i
do have a few fun questions for you if
you're ready
sure all right favorite subject in
middle school or high school
well so i actually came from a
religious school really religious place
and uh what my major was uh
uh israel studies it's like history and
geography
and computers but i did five units
around the
bible and and i basically really liked
the
gemara part to kind of think about it
and ask the right question it was
it was really nice and surprisingly
kind of something that i liked i
haven't had that response yet i love it
perhaps a role model of yours
um yes so so my role model is my
um my grandmother from my uh
father side um she came
with nothing from auschwitz she
after the holocaust she built the
crazy family uh she lost her son
i i'm i was named after my uncle that
got killed in a yom kippur war and she
was still
super positive and always like brought
us to a place that we need to look at
like the the bright side of life and
and be optimistic and see how we can
make the life
of everybody else better i love it
and three words you would use to
describe yourself
uh myself uh father husband
entrepreneur uh not necessarily
in you know in this order but around
that
i love it thank you so so much
continue you know reskilling and
upskilling
the lives of many many people and i
think that what you're touching on here
this idea that you know we get this
traditional education where we're we
destined ourselves for a certain type of
work
early on but the world you know changing
in front of us and even if
we thought one thing in three years it's
going to be different and the ability
for us to absorb this information and to
continue refilling and upskilling
in my mind it's just it's continuing to
provide opportunities to people to make
a change and to
improve and so and to level the playing
field over and over again
every few years i think it's just a
marvelous thank you for coming and
sharing it with me
and best of luck and stay safe and stay
healthy
thank you i love the the coat of james
dean that is saying that if you can't
change the direction of the wind
but you can adjust sales to always reach
your destination and this is like
what i'm saying to companies and to the
employees automation is here
skills are shifting we're in a skills
industry try to see where the wind is
heading
and adjust your sales so dream big and
and thank you for having me again it was
great thank you avi
bye bye